this is fun this is this is really fun i
saw you shared it so i know you know all
about this
so here's what happened to this reporter
she was i can i say
she was basically well let's see what
happened
i love that this is still happening was
their main goal yeah there were some
households
right
[Laughter]
she's so mad she's human she's so mad
she's so mad so this wasn't live this
was recorded of course yeah and then she
tweeted it this isn't funny
and it's not cool as much as i love to
say it doesn't bother me it does
it makes me feel like [ __ ] especially
as a vj who's always alone these
uh this still happens to female
reporters everywhere it needs to stop
okay step one and then i know what are
you about to say go for it
well no just because i even said this on
twitter this has been happening
to male reporters for as long as this
this doesn't happen to female reporters
this happens to
reporters it's not you're being a woman
that we hate you we hate you because
you're a reporter correct
we are we are disturbing your work
because you're a reporter
so the fact that she turned it into some
like um
as a woman it really hurts it's like
dude stop
split you could go find 100 videos on
youtube right now of male
reporters going and i'm done whatever
and i'm live for [ __ ] riding the
blizzard
i'm like all right we'll go again in
three two sometimes
the difference is sometimes the mail
report is you can see giggle a little
bit they kind of they get annoyed but
they're like
all right we gotta do it again so and
this isn't even a political thing at all
it's this isn't a left or right thing
it's a funny thing it's just a prank
it's a plank well this was in canada
look at that look on her face she is by
the way
she must be just a [ __ ] peach to date
oh yeah
she must be so much fun to be around
well you know what's fun is that don't
worry
this is in canada oh i know she got so
many [ __ ] sims coming out 90 check
mark sims
the police the sims yeah waterloo
regional police we're sorry to see this
it is completely unacceptable as chief b
larkin
said we will be looking into this matter
i'm sorry look you're right look i'm not
going to presume to know canada
yeah i'm not going to presume to know
canada but what was illegal about what
they did
everything it's canada
you're still thinking like an american
i'm sure they broke some kind of
canadian law
because canada you know no if you're one
of our canadian listeners
uh cover your ears real quick dude
canadians are
oh really they are like their laws are
[ __ ] they're [ __ ] [ __ ]
they're really only good at like hockey
and
hockey and i mean even then i mean we
still take the stanley cup like half the
time so right 50
of the time they're terrible yeah
canadians suck they like the canadians
invented hockey and then we're like yeah
we're just gonna do that but like better
so hockey's a canadian sport but we
still had to have hockey
down here and then let some of your
canadian teams be part of the american
league like everything about you sucks
canada they ruined her little thing but
when she goes
to somebody's home and knocks on the
door and puts a microphone in their face
and [ __ ] bothers them at their job or
at work that's fine that's okay that's
that's fine but when somebody has a
little tiny little fun at your expense
for five seconds
the world is over in canada yes
yeah i know because again they are very
uh k doolittle says i'm canadian this
country deserves to be dissed
well that's what we're doing um
what is this is that true i have no idea
i just read that too i have no idea but
this sounds real canadians aren't even
allowed to own baseball bats without
being able to prove
they actively pay baseball because it's
considered a deadly weapon
really which i mean
that's the if if if you were only
allowed to sell bats to people who
played baseball
america would be like
like louisville company and all that
stuff they'd be out of business
like 90 of baseball bats are sold
to like bar owners and like people who
own stores that want to
protect their store people are saying
it's not true
uh this is great so why don't we read
some of the comments there's another
verified person
uh afua s awusi
i wish you and your countless others do
not have to deal with this stupidity on
a daily basis
if you haven't already make sure to
report this to your manager
get it on the record and know you've got
a tribe
supporting you but like you can't see us
and you don't know how many of us but
we're here they're acting like this
is footage of a female reporter being
kidnapped by isis
and just being wrapped in a cage for a
week straight like they're acting like
it's the same level of
like i can't believe this happened to
you
and you're like whoa calm down this is
nothing
this is silly this is just silly
so let's read another verified one i'm
sorry this is happening to you it's
normal to feel horrible after
it's a despicable thing to experience
hang in there and stay safe out there
then laurie mccann these are all women
these are notice these are all women
this is disgusting and so wrong i'm so
sorry this is still happening
then david jaworski let's see so smart
of you
to post chris a complete pig oblivious
to his actions and oblivious to the
video camera rolling apparently i hope
she sees this bro
local media like you gives us
information that keeps us informed and
safe
i bet you i bet you really thought for a
sec like
you wrote that whole thing out and
[ __ ]
and i bet you you're like maybe maybe
they'll ask for a cup of coffee
these maybe we'll be friends are so full
full of themselves
they're so full of themselves here's
another journalist okay another
journalist
from canada cindy blackstock sorry this
is happening to you you're a
professional doing an important job and
people need to respect that
thanks for what you do i really want to
know what that report was about i wonder
what important job was she covering a
dog show
linda boylan says thanks for doing what
you do
in highlighting what's unacceptable and
still common you helped end it doing so
thank you you didn't help end it you
know what you did
more people are going to do it now no
more this meme was dead actually this
was a dead meme
now people you've just brought it back
now that we know it bothers you
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] and by the way
when you when he says more people are
going to do it
more people are going to do it
specifically to you lady
you just painted a target on your back
you're good every time this woman's out
she's going to get this now
fair con i'm so sorry this is happening
to you it's not okay you and everyone
deserve a safe workplace craig norris
disgusting i'm so sorry you have been
subjected to such misogynistic moronic
behavior this guy crushes it do you want
to see what he'll see what he looks like
he's pretty cool good host of the
morning edition uh
singer for the kramdens
human man uh
and then this one's great from angie
holman today
uh chris christie j sharp
was the victim of harassment the amount
of sexual harassment universally that
women put upon is beyond sickening
with the layer of being in public eye is
intensified
from comments in the streets to dm
sexual harassment needs to stop
let's speak up but she wasn't like look
she wasn't sexually harassed listen man
when when we watched that video a year
or two ago with a guy ran by and smacked
a chick on the ass
we were all in agreement that that guy
needed to be of course arrested no of
course
not have his heart like he didn't need
to go away for felony sexual assault
but like he needed to be arrested and
and something had to happen because you
can't just run around in 2021 smacking
girls on the ass
especially on live television so like
there are situations where you go okay
that guy needs to be dealt with but like
this woman was not harassed she was not
touched they did not get close to her
they did not threaten her in any way
they literally did the same thing we've
been doing to the media for years
the amount of hysterics that are going
into this is ridiculous
so uh here's another one larry miller i
couldn't tell what they yelled but
obviously it's unacceptable sorry you
had to deal with this kind of thing
if you couldn't tell what they yelled
why would you [ __ ] know if it's
unacceptable
uh let's see penny daflos this is
harassment at the workplace and should
be handled the same way as a postal
worker or teacher
or health care worker faced with such
comments journalists do
our work in a public but that doesn't
mean any kind anything should be
tolerated i'm sorry
that's not harassment in the workplace
because this person doesn't work with
you if he worked with you
yes that if if enough your fellow
journalists worked with you and said
that
you're right and by the way the way that
we handle it with teachers you can tell
your teacher to [ __ ] off
you can't you'll get in trouble you'll
get detention but it's not a crime
you can tell the health care worker you
could tell a nurse to suck your dick
they'll [ __ ] kick you out of the
hospital well
nine times out of ten they will well
you're right
one time out of ten it's gotta work it's
gotta work if you do it enough
i've seen those penthouse [ __ ] deer
penthouse stories this is not what it is
shut up they're acting like she's been
they're acting like she was
live on television she doesn't work
you know if it's not harassment in the
workplace if the other person's not an
employee
it's like dealing with a shitty customer
yeah that's all it is yeah
uh the app so this is from adrian south
the absolute worst sorry had to go
through this i hope they catched him
i had it happen a couple times over the
years and it's definitely violating
can you click on file i want to say
completely unacceptable i want to see
her i want to see if she's actually had
this
okay she's married she might
she might have had some things said to
her
she might have had some things said to
her i think
i'm trying i'm trying to find her here a
little okay here she is
like she's not outrageously she's jewish
she's not outrageously hot
but she looks like a girl that might
have had some things said to her
i'm just saying there's definitely at
least a couple brothers have said some
things to her before
like damn shawty what's up let me get
let me get a look at that fat ass
leslie courtney standing with you sister
it should never happen again let's see
leslie horton
leslie horton hears a who he
all right uh then lucas meyer
sadly people with the emotional maturity
of a diaper can still yell
sorry about this
it's like these guys are all a certain
phenotype
this one specifically hmm
weird no i i don't even mean i just i i
don't even mean the
the jay thing i just mean the they all
look like
bug people like they're all just these
little wormy
like they're these people are all
[ __ ] nerds like
the the fact that we let nerds take over
journalism has been
forget about the [ __ ] people for a
sec
it just just the fact that we let these
[ __ ] beta
nerds take over the journalism machine
has been a disaster for this country
like the old
the reporters in the old days were like
whiskey drinking
cigarettes smoking [ __ ] whoa like
we're tough guys at a bar where
we're i'm gonna get nixon on tape ah
like
like old new you know salty newspaper
reporter types
i'm gonna go write a novel on my off
time and nowadays they're all these i'm
so
sorry that's happening like they just
all turned into these well let's see
what rabbi moishi goldman says
this is messed up a kudos to you for not
pretending for
not pretending to be unperturbed this
should bother all of us
and does with some unfortunate
exceptions please don't let it stop you
though
stop you are you kidding me she loves us
uh wait can you go back up it looks like
somebody tried to blow it up and get his
picture
yeah does this camera have a higher
resolution license is in clear sight
would love
okay you can make them famous and
and so what the guy didn't do anything
wrong
i'm not saying he wasn't being annoying
he was uh
let's see paulie and lisey
uh krista i'm really sorry you have to
put up with babies who probably think
they are
men yelling comments like that please
don't let it get to you
you're doing an amazing job hope you can
pull the plate number from the film and
file a complaint
and then what it is the the fact that
everyone wants to be able to tell on
people for nothing
[Music]
just just not that
it's over nothing yeah i'm gonna fi i'm
gonna dox this person and get up and
file a complaint over nothing
over a minor inconvenience
but remember when cnn docks that kid
well that was different because he was a
racist oh
i see i see i see these jackasses and
you
are a pro i'm sorry david common
the amount of people that are simping
is crazy
ew i think the golden rule for men
should be if you're a man don't say
anything to women on the street that you
wouldn't want a man saying to you in
prison
eww this is this this is
the future this is the future
this so look at this look man it doesn't
stop and and this is why
we won't stop creating victims because
this is what happens
they get all the attention they want
nobody ever knew who this woman was
before yesterday right
yeah absolutely now she's famous for for
a stupid prank
but blank
take solace in the knowledge that you're
doing important work
and offenders like that uh are condemned
to a lifetime of mediocrity
insecurity and overcompensating
uh it's not cute it happens far too
often and only makes people acting like
this
the camera look immature and foolish
yeah that's the that's the point
the whole point is to just be immature
and foolish since the last time we saw
you just a couple of minutes ago
i'm gonna put it out there right now i'm
saying it
we any of you live in cities we we all
see news
cameras and [ __ ] set up with all the
time at little car accidents things like
that
we all need to make a concerted effort
in 2021.
if you see a [ __ ] film crew doing
this kind of [ __ ]
you get behind them and you'll [ __ ] them
right in the [ __ ] male or female
it doesn't matter who they are this is
not this is not course
any if you see a news van and somebody's
setting up
you [ __ ] wait you go there you get
behind the shot and you yell
[ __ ] them right in the [ __ ] let's bring
it back now let's bring it back
now now we'll bring it back full time
the fact that the media are acting like
their hero i really
really love the [ __ ] just this is
partly because of
especially after trump they all think
that they're all fighting like they're
fighting a good fight they're all active
they're all they're speaking truth to
power bro they're all woodward and
bernstein they're all the same you know
i'm like you no you're not they're
speaking truth to power
no you're not no you're not you're doing
these stupid [ __ ] things on the
street
i'm sorry did you defeat trump no i
didn't think so you've been replaced by
the internet you [ __ ]
also have you read like have you ever
like
i've noticed when i read articles too
like they're
all the misspellings the terrible
grammar like
the funny thing is about these reporters
is that they're not even good at the
rapport i know they're not like they're
not even good at writing
they're not good at english it's very
funny to me
when they were when they wrote the uh
the d live hit piece
the two that wrote that article were
like
the first sentence of the article was so
illegible and made no sense
because these these girls just don't
they don't proofread
these these newspapers have been cutting
back for years they don't have editors
anymore they don't have a copy desk they
don't have like
a senior guy that these people hand
their article to that looks it over and
makes them rewrite it ten times
there is none of that anymore they just
pop it in as fast as they can to get the
clicks
and it's garbage here's stonewall from a
couple years ago
i was doing an interview outside of the
hamilton police headquarters today
with a a you a uniformed police officer
when a man yelled [ __ ] a ride in the
[ __ ]
police heard him and arrested him for
causing a disturbance you could watch
yourself
so they are arrested somebody so you're
promoting this though
you're also promoting this can we check
the hashtag
well yeah but i wanted to
i wanted to uh see if they had the
footage no i guess they don't
no i i don't so i was gonna say like so
you're basically saying like oh yeah the
same thing happened to me it was the
word it was horrible people shouldn't
have to see that but
you can see the footage live tonight at
6 00 p.m on channels like what
we see he's like stop man
hate these people
this needs to happen 24 hours a day
and this is the man that started it
there he is remember him the rules
he's the og he was the og
but his spirit lives on yeah free speech
is a crime now you're not allowed to say
anything you're not
you're go you gotta be a drag queen and
read a kid book so that's fine
they acted like this woman was on camera